d5 is a really good try g5 is a great  try yeah  that was that was by far objective well  maybe even objectively the best but  practically  maybe he's taking it  you believe in me seat belts fastened  and mandatory yeah yeah all right  now we're gonna get some craziness  before rook 81 is coming i mean rook 81  is absolutely forced  there are simply no other ideas and it's  young playing it immediately is the  episode is queen or can he play bishop  c5  he could play bishop c5 but after king  f1 i was like yeah he sacked his queen  he played rook chase doing it yeah let's  see  yeah this is better yeah  is there any chance magnus didn't see  rookie five  is there any chance absolutely no this  is over  yeah i don't see him moving over i don't  see a movie could play that makes any  sense  i think he just resigned magnus agreed  venus agrees with our assessment